scandals at the highest levels of
Virginia's government or force in some
of the state's younger residents to have
difficult conversation these days about
race after a racist photo was discovered
on governor Ralph Northam 's 1984
yearbook page he and the state's third
highest ranking official admitted that
they wore black face when they were
younger men this week students at Mary
Ellen Henderson Middle School in
Northern Virginia spent their civics
class learning about the history of
blackface CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller met some of them
after class she's here with what they've
learned I'm curious about this
conversation good morning to you good
morning they're bright they're brilliant
I live to say from some of the first
slave landings to the capital of the
Confederacy to more recent fights over
historical monuments Virginia has had a
long and complicated racial history but
after a searching conversation about the
history of black base and how we treat
each other a group of seventh graders at
Henderson middle school found a way to
talk about race we could all learn from
[Music]
for some students in mr. buck seventh
grade civics class their governor's
famous admission was news to them a dark
in my face is part of a Michael Jackson
costume what exactly is blackface to
help explore the issue blackface has a
long history in our country mr. buck
showed a 2018 story from CBS Sunday
morning the history of blackface is long
and complex and then asked his students
what they thought everyone should learn
from their mistakes
after class we talked about governor nor
them and the day's lesson with Matthew
patron Zeppelin Atilla hon sir Ron hey
Roy me of Rodriguez and Cary heard
show of hands how many of you believe
your governor should step down if he
owned up to it said sorry this wouldn't
be a huge deal and I feel like he
wouldn't have to step down if he's lying
then we don't know what else he's been
lying about
when you first saw that picture what
went through your mind I was thinking
how dumb would you have to be to like
put paint on your face and then put it
in your medical school yearbook and get
it published in his recent interview
with CBS this morning governor Northam
sparked a new controversy over
Virginia's painful past the first
indentured servants from Africa landed
on our shores and Old Point Comfort what
we call now Fort Monroe and Wow also
known as slavery yes do you know what
that is
did you have a problem with that ninja
servitude is when you should get a chip
on a boat and then you pay off though
trip with the labor y'all know they were
slaves because they weren't paid and
they're beaten up and it's just it was
so scary because he's our governor this
controversy comes less than two years
after a white nationalist rally turned
violent in Charlottesville Virginia I
was there when that happened actually
you were there as well yeah it was scary
and also I'm Jewish so that was also
kind of like an eye-opener for me I feel
like because like there are still people
that are anti-semitic anti-black anti
whatever do you see all of this tied
together I mixed so sometimes like white
people are mad at you for being part
black and black people pretty you for
being part white I remember what that
felt like is it important to talk about
these tough issues yes
yeah she's talked about it it could like
be resolved yeah if you talk about it it
can get resolved do you think Americans
haven't really talked about it they
haven't put herself in someone else's
shoes I don't think if they had thought
about different perspectives
I started starting to be called the
n-word at third grade and the school
wouldn't deal with it I'm sorry bus I
can still hear people saying it in the
back what's the most surprising thing
you've learned out of this but there is
a still a lot of racism in the u.s. what
surprised me the most is that like
people still think that it's fun to do
it to do
black face even though like it has a
really bad history behind it I want it
to be better here because I want I don't
want my sister to have to experience the
things I had experience you know this is
a really diverse school they have had
some problems here but they have
addressed it primarily because of that
young man who is mixed and he he really
said you know the pain of it all is is
what people need to understand you make
an impact on people when you hurt them
and hurt people hurt people and I tell
you Matthew the young man who spoke so
much to the interview he had a really
good point he said you know what he said
when things like this happen in the
state of Virginia it makes me look bad
and I am NOT about what this is all
about now I want people to know that and
none of us in this room are and people
need to know that you know Virginians
are good people there are some great
people in the state or prevent it's
right about that but those kids were so
young and so wise we suppress with all
of them all of them I would do very good
point and express themselves so well
welcome to trajectory from any eighties
yearbook even 2019 and they're still
having to deal with these issues hope
they're and they're talking about it the
main thing is they're talking about
nicely that was a really nice
conversation thank you really right with
them kids were great